all right team white the Grob let's not
and say we did this is called the let's
not and say we did attack
okay French land alright I'm gonna go
with this and and this is fantastic
commentary I can say that after every
move right let's go with this and this
doing though what is it doing okay so c5
is typical and now this is a typical but
I'm gonna do it because this is my bad
guy and this is their good guy and I
would love to go here this night right
now has a dream he has a dream of d6
that's where he wants to be I promise
you I'm making this stuff up this is my
furthest advanced pawn this right here
needs to be taken care of
ah my opponents saying you will not go
here so easily
hmm what I do in response to that I'm
not used to seeing that
okay whoa this is actually a line this
is the French Widow our advance BOGO I'm
not gonna I can't pronounce that name
beau beau glowed you both variation that
was an okay try anyhow what are you
doing response to that I haven't seen it
so I just take here I want to do that oh
let's grab that pot Knight f3 there's a
d3 castle I think that has some appeal
to me excuse me um so I mean I'm not
advancing my development here I what I
did for a split second consider Knight e
to but I really didn't like going
backwards I saw that just takes Queen
takes chopped 96 pressure on both of
these squares so I really I don't want
to end up having to have a piece on this
square I think I just maybe want to
focus more so on just maintaining my e5
pawn for sure so and if I'm not careful
maybe it should I consider f4 first
should I consider a knight here to here
well I might want to try that now maybe
my opponent should have immediately
recaptured on c5 what are my candidate
moves Knight d5 Knight f3 f4 this seems
to be the most forcing this is this is a
stupid piece anyhow I don't know how do
I even want to allow black to give up
the bishop for night so I'm discounting
night here forget about it who cares
about that I think black would be more
than happy to do that unless there's a
way I can maybe hang on the c5 pawn
after that
I think he's gonna come under fire I
want to make sure I maintain this pun oh
but then again the bishop takes here and
now I'm gonna have a little bit of
trouble recap or the I recapturing
castling recasting of trouble recasting
can't I counsel twice please
Knight f3 Bishop d3 Queenie - maybe
Bishop here but then there's maybe Forks
happening I'm gonna see about that
aren't we okay first things first
throw that night out there it is there
really a better spot for him no no there
isn't it's a good question I think
that's a good enough answer right there
it's his best home f3 if you're going
elsewhere with your king Knight - if you
if you don't go to f3 or f6 oh man what
was I gonna say I lost my train of
thought after Queen b6 was played I
better play here it's pretty scary over
here an f2 what I was gonna say is you
better have a good reason to not go to
f3 or f6f-3 with the white knight f6
there okay my king is officially on
Castle and I don't know how annoying
that is though let's go here the Queen
is for the most part am I talking about
for the most part the queen is tethered
to the bishop quick get in fancy alright
now what what about a tree
what about rookie here and then pawn
push does that scare black and mine I
should probably go quick I can't go here
should I go 83 be for a rookie one pawn
plush with a three ensuing pin or
something I'm gonna go here a now if a
five I'll play a four and then maybe
focus on this square get my knight here
and then follow up with c3 I should
probably get my King Castle this rook is
stupid oh boy oh but wait a second I
think there's trouble now for black
trouble time oh why did I see that wait
though can we get the Queen's off can we
get those Queens off can I deflect the
Queen away from the defense of the
bishop no I want to get the Queen's off
my king is not so happy not a happy
camper however hang on check check Queen
out I think the King runs over here if I
do that take King takes Knight here
check King here this Queen is just too
annoying I gotta get rid of her
you gotta go Queen could I be sneaky
with rook b3 Knight takes pawn bishop
takes here sneakiness this nights gonna
go here if I'm not if I'm not addressing
this Queens position quickly it's off
for a queen exchange if you have um okay
if you have a piece that's or if your
King is more vulnerable if your King is
more vulnerable get the Queen's off it's
a good tip just like you know if you got
material trade pieces anyhow so d4 is
now springing to mind for me I want to
pivot about on that square I think
Bishop here was a possibility
another possibility even at this point
is 97 with Bishop b5 to follow my king
needs to play this is gonna be um a bit
tricky and I think this is still good
okay I get rid of this Knight hang on I
like that I like my bishop too much my
bishop serving a good role watching over
this and I think I need a better King
position sneak
over here and well I still think that
that move is good hmm it's got to be
good however soon as the night moves
I'll play here or something I want to
maybe get this advance in and if I'm
from if I'm Dunham overnight to d4 it's
gonna be this night because I want my
knight on f3 to watch over the e5 square
so the often times I think if there's
two different nights that could go to
the same square you bring the one that
is closest to the edge of the board
that's a real firm you could file the
one that's closest to the edge of the
board in that different in that on that
square so in this case the e2 Knight was
closer to the edge so if there is this
capture I have enough support for this I
have to recapture with my knight tell
you at the time okay now this is a
potential passed pawn at any moment I
could press forward here pass pawn okay
this is oh hang on though hang on hang
on hang on I might want to get moving
faster okay let's get this pawn going my
knight is a monster isn't he
isn't he a monster let's take with the
pawn I want to do this and pawn push or
something we're gonna have a bunch of
trades this is a rook ending and I think
I stand better is it simplifies more and
more I think I want to get one rook off
and then pawn push here let's do this
pawn push and then pawn push pawn push
or something
if this pawn pushes oh it's not pushing
so now I think I get active let me throw
a check-in chase the King away from
defensive this and now get the pig here
33 seconds I got to go quicker I'll take
this and then this and now I have pawn
push next right here pac-man mode I got
to go quicker though check and then pawn
push two times is the threat I get this
pawn the king should go back to g8 let's
try it again
King position next I got this pawn my
king wants to be on e5 e 5 next give a
check a couple times maybe
oh that's annoying
give a check give a check give a check
give a check now the king is in trouble
that's me oh it was a it was like a
delayed mate or something first I was me
and then it wasn't coming up right away
I think the King just needed to stick
back here but man turned out to be made
there I got a little excited or a lot
excited there oh man as usual good fight
Ben koji let's see French win a war and
again from what they were referencing
here on chess cube I don't know how
accurate these always are but it's
referencing EC au code after this point
right here so French Widow are after
this Bishop d7 move you can't see it on
the stream right now but as I'm
scrolling here it says after Bishop d2
it's the French it's ECL code see 17 if
you're curious about that those that
know about the encyclopedia of chess
openings it's the French Way no our
advance
bogel Oh Chabot of variation BOGO
variation I don't know what are my other
choices I think that this is still okay
maybe f4 maybe not stupid maybe I should
go with this is immediate Knight f3 get
more development in I think it was okay
to just take away from the center all
right nothing nothing jumping right out
at me and okay well this is a bit
annoying
maybe this right here I think I do okay
after I have be foreign that's my rough
assessment right here so maybe it's
important to just prevent that I was
during the game talking about that if a
for I could put excuse me if a five I
could play a four in response and then
maybe pivot about on this square b5 but
I think it's still worthwhile just so I
don't
start kicking this bishop around when
you do comparison of Bishops I think um
well I know blacks is just doing so much
better
um I'm definitely in favor of getting
the dark square Bishop Soph the board
judging just by by my pawn structure
here I'm still welcoming that just as I
was when I initially developed it to d2
I was saying that I wanted to get rid of
my my bishop therefore that well I don't
know if I said that but I wanted to play
Knight b5 exchange darts or bishops and
then get to d6 but anyhow I think after
I played b4 and we have this dark square
Bishop exchange this starts to favor me
a little bit more whereas if you just
play a 5 right here and I still have
some work to do I definitely have some
work to do I think this is a good idea
the castles or maybe am I missing
something right now my hull of tension
right here has been on this B floor move
but did I miss an opportunity earlier
only once the only when the Queen was on
e3 did I start to consider Bishop takes
h7 but this was here for maybe a while
Bishop takes King takes Knight g5 and
then the King has to go to one of these
two is otherwise Queen h5 and then
there's serious trouble for black mm
what's the fault
yeah it's it's and there's an additional
piece around if the King does go there
let's say Bishop takes King takes Knight
check this is another reason not to
castle in this position
there's definitely possibilities for
some tactical shots I don't know about I
don't know if I'm I'm not gonna be able
to do all the number crunching on this
but it really does look pretty scary for
black maybe after Bishop takes here
maybe that's the more direct reason not
to Castle kingside right now and so
maybe a 5 is gonna be better a missed
opportunity maybe for me I don't know
but once we get into this endgame I
think okay this is fine
rook after c8 night there okay well that
turned out to be a waste of time so and
I don't know that you can really exploit
I don't know that this is a bad thing
like a weakness this is where I want to
be anyhow this is my furthest advance
pawn so it's just facilitating an
eventual pawn duo on f5 and E 5 so you
can do without that sure that's a a bit
more clear and I like this repositioning
getting to this square that's important
trades and I guess yeah it is a bit
awkward for you to defend that maybe you
should still hang tight here maybe it's
maybe you should try this knight c6
we're still it seems like in nearly
every variation it's coming down to like
because my opponent has this light
square bishop there's possibilities for
either good versus bad Bishop ending or
good night versus bad bishop and earlier
when I was saying I think I was
considering Knight B 5 and then well I
thought about it for a while and then I
eventually came to the conclusion you
know what I don't even want to go there
because this Bishop I don't want this
bishop to give itself up for anything so
that earlier decision to not do that is
now allowing for me right now to maybe
enter certain variations where I could
have the good versus bad bishop or the
good night versus the bad bishop so I
think maybe just hang tight with here
maybe that may be the best the best
thing to do is get the Knights off the
board I think this is just he's a beast
you gotta get rid of this guy I think
that's maybe a number-one priority and
as a follow up I think once the Knights
are off then try this Bishop b5 move and
if I'm to take then you recapture the
pawns look ugly but I do not know how
accessible they are what I do know is
that your rook gets great activity so
maybe that's a good plan of action for
black instead of taking on f5 hold this
structure you have enough support for
every move this
and then as your next step trying to get
rid of the light square bishop with
Bishop to b5 I think that would maybe be
a better try you follow that 96 let's
just say Knight takes Bishop takes with
Bishop b5 to follow so no I think it's
kind of tough I have good rook activity
and a strong Knight and can quickly
create a passed pawn we're in a time
scramble here and material is dropping
eat this King position you might want to
even view as being you know me being up
just a pawn just because of the King
position alone when you do a King King
versus King assessment so yeah that's
that's my main suggestion at least when
it comes down to this endgame and how to
maybe treat it he's your number one
priority to get rid of him and then the
LightSquared Bishop s' okay good game as
usual